hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from round one of the
Baku open uh it is a game between uh
women Grandmaster Divya Deshmukh and
Hans smoker Neiman and it features a
very cool line of the night of variation
of the Sicilian uh the the English
attack or the burn attack but one we're
very early on in the game you will have
a white Bishop on B6 and the White
Knight on C7 it's a light a line I've
seen being played in bullet I've seen it
being played in Blitz I haven't seen it
being played in classical so I'm sure
you guys will enjoy this one uh Diva
Edition last year's India is a Women's
National Champion uh and of course I
believe Hans Neiman needs no
introduction so let's check it out Divya
has the white pieces and she opens with
Ponte E4 we have C5 as advertised the
Sicilian defenses on the board Knight F3
D6 capture uh D4 captures captures
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and of course
Pawn 36 the Knight of variation is on
the board and here we have Bishop to E3
she goes for the English attack or the
burn attack this is
um for those of you who are maybe new to
chess this position is so popular and so
common in chess that every move you make
here has a name you can't make a move
here and that it doesn't have a name of
a you know a strong Grand Master of or a
tournament where it was played or a
country or you know something so here
Bishop to E3 uh the the English for the
burn attack and not Ponte E5 this is the
classical way to challenge the burn
attack with Knight to F3 Knight to B3 is
still by far the most popular she goes
Knight to F3 with Bishop to E7 Bishop to
C for fighting for that D5 Square uh and
here Castles by Hans and here uh castles
by white is the most popular move but
she goes for Queen to E2 it's only been
played a handful of times uh most
notable yeah player to play it I believe
is it was Kevin spraggett all the way
back in 1986 uh he played it against
Alexi Ortega and
um uh well the game deviated from this
one but that is the the the oldest one
that I found so here Ponte B5
challenging the bishop Bishop to D5
attacking The Rook here and not just
trades captures captures and now Bishop
to B7 this is the star move of the game
and it is not as of move seven that we
as move 11 that we have a completely new
game usually people just played Knight
um at the D7 here to stop Knight to B6
but Hans actually invites it so Bishop
to B7 and uh now we see it it's only
move 12 but we see Bishop to B6
attacking the queen queen D7 and Knight
the C7 trapping hunts his Rook on A8 uh
so what do you what do you make of this
what's the point of this well the reason
why Hans went with this bishop to B7
idea is that he will also win the E4
Pawn uh so he will be down the Rook but
he will keep the bishop pair he will be
up upon he will have a strong Center and
it's definitely an interesting trade-off
and well if you play the if you're a
fighting player if you play the Knight
of Sicilian this is exactly what you are
looking for uh in a game so here Queen
to C6 to put more pressure on the pawn
here and the bishop on B6 she captures
The Rook Bishop capture and now of
course Bishop to A7 the bishop here was
hanging so here at Knight the D7 and uh
here she just castles there's no
defending the pawn if you play Knight to
D2 to defend the pawn then you also lose
the C2 Pawn uh so here she castles uh
and Hans first goes after the bishop a
queen B7 attacks the bishop on A7 Bishop
back to A3 and now he captures the pawn
on e4 and this was the trade-off that we
discussed uh Hans has the bishop pair he
has the strong Center if he gets D5 D4
in it's hard to even imagine a position
where black will be worse so uh it's not
going to be easy playing this even being
up the exchange so Rook after D1 and
I'll just spawn to F5 Hans is now ready
to advance the F and the E Pawn maybe
even the d-pawn she offers the queen
trade with Queen D3 and Hans declines it
of course as the pawns are now marching
forward and it's very easy for him to
develop his pieces he can play Rook F6
Rook to G6 the Knight has very simple
ways of entering the game the bishop
here is an absolute monster and you well
a few more moves will be played before
this Rook uh an A1 sees the light of day
so Knights the E1 uh the defending
Checkmate Here and Now Pawn to F4
preparing Pawn to F3 and now if you just
move the bishop let's say Bishop D2 or
Bishop C1 f 3 is coming and yeah you can
pretty much call it a day so she has to
play this nice session two point F3
attacks the queen queen H5 and now
Bishop to F2 allows um her to continue
fighting so here we have Pawn to E4 Hans
doesn't want to waste any time uh so he
starts uh strong you could also prepare
it with with D5 you could also play some
like King it shade some you know uh
standard attacking moves here but he
goes for E4 right away F captures an E4
and now Knight to E5 where he had to
move the pawn in order to vacate the
five square for the Knight Queen to B3
with check King to h8 uh like I said
that's why you could also consider King
date there because you know that Queen
B3 will happen in this line but you also
don't mind it and here Queen to E6 which
is a great move by Divya uh going after
the bishop on E7 you can't really move
it because this uh loses the pawn on D6
sohan's has to go back defend the bishop
and now Knight to F3 and now how do you
continue this you could run her Pawn
structure with some like Knight captures
and pawn captures but this also fixes
her
Central e for a weakness problem because
the bishop now is not nearly as powerful
as it was a move ago so of course Hans
not interested in this he just plays
Rook to F6 kicks the queen away next
he's gonna capture on e4 and then even
The Rook can join the king hunt so Queen
back to B3 and now Bishop captures on e4
we have Knight captures on E5 aside from
this you could also try Bishop to D4
it's a really fun line that um maybe
allows a bit too much for the attack
let's say Knight captures G captures now
the the F Pawn is nicely defended Rook
the G6 check into H1 and now Queen to C6
how are you how are you stopping this
bishop captures and F3 you can't capture
because Queen captures leads the
Checkmate but after Rook F1 it seems
that white holds it's a really ugly
position to play and you know hold but
uh objectively it it does hold however
she went for a different line after
Queen capture Bishop captures an E4 she
went for Knight captures on E5 D
captures on E5 this kind of fixes hans's
Pawn structure and now Rook does E1
challenges the bishop and now Hans goes
back with Queen the A8 here the move to
consider was also Pawn to F3 it's a
really wild move because you kinda
sacrifice a piece here but after Rook
captures there's Queen to G6 now
threatening Checkmate and you have to
give back material so so now that
obviously G3 Queen captures an E4 and
now Rook to E1 and it seems white is
defending let's say queen to G4 now
trying to Checkmate white you have to
play Queen to D3 and now if Queen H3
Queen to F1 okay you've defended Queen
F5 then E4 is coming and the white will
still struggle a lot but maybe
and maybe you can save it uh so Queen
day 8 was played Hans says that there's
a better way uh and now just Rook
captures an E4 uh the reason why she
gives up The Rook so easily is that uh
how do you defend here if you try how do
you stop Bishop captures on G2 if you
try something like Queen to H3 uh then
uh how do you defend uh how do you
attack you can't really go uh Rook the
G6 right away to put pressure on the G2
Pawn because Rook captures an E4 now
wins for white because if after Queen
captures there's Queen to C8 to check
you're getting checkmated once the
bishop Retreats and you capture it
however after Queen to H3 Hans would
play something like H6 and then how do
you continue let's say Rook AC one you
defend the pawn here Rook to G6 cannot
come pulling pressure on the G2 pawn and
now you have to play G3 so you you would
get a position like this like the king
to each seven the game continues but
white is really struggling here so that
would that would be the other
possibility however she went for Rook
captures and E4 right away Queen
captures an E4 and now Rook the E1 this
is how she gets The Rook into the game
Queen to F5 and now Queen to D5 stopping
the advance of the pawn because then she
can just trade Queens but also you know
you you have to be careful of of any
back rank ideas for the moment Queen and
Rook are stopping that with with
regarding of that f8 square uh but uh
you know yeah and you can never be
careful enough so Queen captures on C2
now puts pressure on that um uh Bishop
here uh Rook captures on E5 it's a trade
and now Bishop to f8 this is how Hans
will defend against Checkmate uh and now
she plays Queen to d8 which is uh pretty
much the the start of her downfall here
the bishop and F2 is is a terrible piece
and if you want to survive you have to
play Bishop to H4 attack the rook and
only after The Rook moves you will play
something like rook d8 and continue your
attack then comes Rook to C8 and so on
uh sorry that's a weird Arrow but in the
game she played Queen to d8 right away
attacking the bishop here or rather
pinning the bishop but now the problem
is the F3 square is no longer guarded
twice so Hans just advances the pawn
pawn to F3 and now how do you defend she
played Rook to E8 if you capture on F3
which is also possible then this happens
Rook captures an F3 the threatening uh
captures and Checkmate uh Bishop to E1
would block but now Queen C4 threatens
uh mating one and after Bishop to F2
stopping that you can even grab another
Pawn now you're up to pawns and you're
just winning so it's not really
spectacular if Rook to A8 you can just
bring the queen back Queen to F7 you
defend against everything you're up to
pawns completely winning so instead Rook
d8 was played right away she's now
threatening to win the game but Hans
plays Queen to C1 with check and now
Rook the E1 you can defend with the
bishop If you defend with the bishop F
to check and this game over King H1 F1
Rook or queen will be checkmate
uh so I have to clean the C1 check uh
she had the block with Rook that you
want now comes Queen capture some B2
Hanzo grabs the First Pawn of many uh H3
uh you can't really move the bishop
otherwise you're just gonna get
checkmated so H3 was played and now even
F captures and G2 grabbing another pawn
and threatening now the bishop on F2 so
Bishop the D4 was played attacking
hans's Queen and Rook but now just to
Rook the F1 with check uh we have Rook
captures uh uh on F1 G captures now
bringing a queen into the game with
check King captures and now you have to
be very careful uh but uh it's also very
easy to win this queen to B1 check was
played and he was in this position on
move 40 uh that Diva deshmuk resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here she's down two pawns already
and she will now lose another one
because once um yeah she moves the king
Hans will just gobble up that pawn with
check and now whatever you play with the
King to F3 just King to G8 and you are
defending this it's not a problem you're
you're up to pawns the pawn will just
Advance forward for some reason my
camera disappeared but we've we've
already shown the game so I'm not going
to worry about that and the problem is
uh here if you try Bishop to C5 let's
say you go after that Bishop on f8 to
just Queen the B3 check now if you go up
the board then you can even lose a
bishop with the check so here Bishop D3
would have to be played and then you
play B4 you start advancing those pawns
and there's really no good way to uh to
handle this uh so yeah really a a really
nicely played by both of them but in the
end Hans takes the win and uh yeah very
interesting line of the night of like I
said I've seen this uh played in bullet
I've seen it played in Blitz but I've
never seen it done in a classical game
this bishop to B6 Knight to C7 move so
really really interesting stuff uh so
yeah okay my camera died so I'm not
gonna uh you know I should just end the
video now uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Russell Jack Wesley Carter Marco
boots
tester and Edmund Freeman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my videos uh previous
videos here on the screen on the left
you can see me pointing at them with my
finger because I'm not really here
so yeah that's pretty much it thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day